Hello world,
it's Serrano and I'm the director of a
nonprofit organization called school of
AI dedicated to offering a worldclass AI
education to anyone on earth for free.
I'm now looking for an entirely new
class of school of AI staff called
residential advisers to help provide
quality low cost housing for school of Ai
students across the world. Link to sign
up. We'll be in the video description.
In just four months.
We built a highly engaged network
of deans across 400 cities globally.
These deans are hosting regular in person
classes that teach a wide variety of
topics in technology to students and have
been very successful in creating fast
growing connected communities.
Because of their association
with school of Ai.
There are personal brands
have grown as well.
We're seeing them get invited to
public speaking events, interviews.
They're generally becoming thought
leaders in this space. Additionally,
we have multiple online
offerings including full
courses and curriculums that
detail various learning paths for
students. We've given our students,
which we endearingly call wizards,
educational opportunities,
both online and offline,
but we're committed to providing a full
stack learning experience globally.
That means we're looking
to provide housing as well.
Residential advisors provide quality
coal living housing for school of Ai
Wizards in their respective cities.
We're looking for people who either own
or lease rent or in some way manage a co
living property with at least five beds,
but the more the better the
type of property can be.
A big house on apartment complex,
a hostel or even an existing college dorm.
Co-Living living is a growing trend in
the sharing economy that allows residents
an opportunity to share their living
space with others who share similar values
and interests.
I used to manage a 20 bedroom coal
living community in San Francisco for two
years and can vouch for
the benefits of co living.
I made lifelong friends there and learn
a lot from my roommates across a wide
variety of technical topics.
Kol living is an evolution of the
dormitory model that colleges have
traditionally offered,
but education is no longer a four year
endeavor that will fulfill all skill set
requirements for a job for
the rest of your lifetime.
Technology is rapidly changing every
aspect of society and in order to remain
relevant in this field,
we have to move to a model of
continuous lifetime education.
Ai Is the new electricity.
It is fast becoming a crucial elements
to every business across every industry
to help make better data driven decisions,
products and services.
That's where school of
AI campuses come in.
Our residents will come
from all walks of life,
all backgrounds and all ages.
It's not just for millennials.
We've already partnered with our first
residential advisor in San Francisco
named James [inaudible] naira.
James manages an existing
52 bedroom community,
has his own brand and an existing
applicant pipeline associated with it.
What we're doing is acting as a global
realtor that will bring him high quality
housing candidates with an
interest in AI technology for free.
If you have an existing brand and
landing page, that's totally fine.
We'll build an application form for
new residents that will fit into your
existing applicant's pipeline and work
with you to ensure all the details fit
your needs.
I understand that maintaining occupancy
levels at 100% can be a challenge,
so having school of Ai Wizards occupied
a portion of your property is fine.
You don't have to reserve every
room for school of AI applicants,
but they should get preferential access.
As our community grows,
so will the pool of applicants and we
believe that eventually we'll be able to
provide more than enough applicants
to occupy the entire property.
We take no profit from this.
We just want to provide a safe living
space to our community that helps them
grow and connect with their peers.
If you manage any type of Co living
property, be it urban, rural,
and network of multiple properties.
A remote island apply using the Google
form in the video description to join our
team. We are open to all forms
of living arrangements. Ideally,
there are multiple options,
meaning both shared rooms and
private rooms. Once accepted,
we'll add your name and campus to our
global directory and promote it every
week.
That means a consistent pipeline of
technology focused applicants that share a
set of values.
Residential advisers get access to a
private slack channel that I'll personally
be engaging with daily, just like I
currently do in the Dean's channel.
First access to any school of AI
announcements via our newsletter and a
collection of resources to
help grow their community.
Each of our residential advisers will
receive a poster with our seven values and
mission that they can hang somewhere
on the wall on the property.
They are expected to help organize weekly
study sessions amongst residents and
provide a basic set of amenities.
That means that residents
will pay one monthly fee,
decided by the residential advisors
that will include the rent, utilities,
Wifi, basic supplies, cleaning services,
and easy access to a washer and dryer
school of AI campuses are meant to offer
each resident wizard academic support
in the form of weekly study sessions.
The ability to live with peers and a
resident advisor that supports their
learning journey.
They'll also have their basic amenities
taken care of so they can focus more of
their time and energy on learning.
And of course a vibrant built in social
life in the form of roommates and access
to local school of AI events.
We are keeping applications open for
only two weeks. So if you are interested,
apply now.
We'll start promoting each of our campuses
to the larger community so they can
apply to be residents shortly after that.
Wizards,
if you don't manage a big
property, but no, someone who does,
please refer them to this
video so they can apply.
I need your help on this one.
Let's upgrade education together.
Please subscribe for more
programming videos. And for now,
I've got to serve my wizards,
so thanks for watching.